foundati everybody has something
everybody everybody's born with that
gift that that seed of some sort of and
for me it was my voice I heard it I had
a natural ear and anyone what you felt
that you loved it you knew you had
something different you said I've got to
just go with well I got attention for it
just like you did if you got a smile
from your father that's attention and
from attention from from somebody saying
wow you're good I got that from a music
teacher in school when I was in
kindergarten next thing you know I had a
solo right I'm the only kindergartener
with a solo with the third grade with
the glee club so it just forms from
there but you know from there that's the
only place where you're feeling good
right it's a high it's it's that place
except it was a thank God and natural
and and something that was at least a
healthy diversion if you will but in my
mind I was like well you hear that radio
you hear this little thing my father
gave me that little transistor a turbo
do you hear that voice who's that holy
[ __ ] that's Stevie Wonder how his life
looks really happy he looks happy and
not only that he's getting paid you know
what I mean and he's got a lot of
girlfriends and why do you think you did
it he's blind well that was his problem
not exact everybody's problem like look
right I mean I heard her read the Frank
I heard a lot of people on that you know
Marvin Gaye everybody has something
there's always something you're fighting
against did your father ever break down
and just cry to you and say all the time
even today my father came into the room
after those explosives moments in my
room right after he exploded
hell no three hours later when I'm
talking about things that have know when
you're on eggshells and when you're in a
PT you know a traumatic you're there's
no certainties
there was no certainties when my father
came back how many times the door would
slam and he'd leave and when you come
back so I was constantly in hyper
vigilance of listening I always was
listening I was listening when he came
home to get myself ready prepared for
war all the time and then he would come
in and he would stand at the door you're
my favorite child you're my the love of
my life you're so special you're this
this is deep well if you talk to a
therapist now sure at the time it made
me feel secure that I knew I was really
ultimately loved but you know what in
relationships it made me have to watch
somebody crawl through fire to love me I
think on some level I mean that had
cup your relationships I'm sure I mean I
look at you now and I look at me and
we're both single yeah and I wonder if
you know Singh dysfunction so much
dysfunction as a kid made us just go ah
I don't know I don't I can guarantee it
but what is it what is it that you like
what do you want to be with somebody
like have you been massively and l'm
madly in love with someone where you're
just like [ __ ] this is it yeah I have
you have yeah and you felt safe and it
wasn't dysfunctional till I didn't feel
safe and what didn't make you feel safe
um well lack of commitment moving it to
the next something that wasn't moving it
although my best relationships when you
think about him although I wasn't
invested in it because I was completely
invested in Fame and moving my career
all through my tour I mean that was my
investment I married this and I all I
and I net it wasn't for women like oh
you can get pregnant and have a career
we weren't kardi being it back then it
was like you don't talk about who you
[ __ ] you don't get pregnant and you
say on the road I'm sorry that's how it
was and like usually it's your boyfriend
that's you know what boyfriend was
running my show
I wasn't Patti Benatar I wasn't Debbie
Harry they weren't the bleed guitar
player I wasn't you know I was like his
Pat Benatar was married to her you know
who really is fought who did it
Madonna on her terms on her you know did
it her way